qu'est-ce qu'on fout
là ça sent le
slip on avait tout tu étais une star tu
t'en
souviens est-ce que vous ne craignez pas
qu'on dis que vous montez cette pièce
pour vous débarrasser de cette image de
superhéros au RC qui vous colle à la
peau pas du tout c'est même tout le
contraire puisquil y a déjà 20 ans j'ai
refusé de participer au tournage deman
4 faitman
4 PAP tu sais pouro parce que tu as trop
la trouille d'être comme tout le monde
la trouille de pas compter et maintenant
tu vas en l'air ce qui reste de
ta carrière on aurait d accepter cette
émission de
téléalitéle sais que j'ai
raison com à
faireier tuisesser deoser tuas pas
compris c'est toi le vrai
superhéros on va faire
notreb
tu
es tu es un
Dieu ch tonost d'oiseau ta
[Musique]
per on vaettreun FO mon de quoi on est
capable j'ai chance
àis
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
arrête de sourire comme ça tu me fais
flipper